Chelsea Clinton is a special
correspondent for Rock Center with Brian
T or special correspondent special card
there's a lot of air quotes in this one
on Rock Center with Brian Williams and
she's been getting a little guff for
some of the softball pieces she's been
doing let's take a look at this one hi
Gekko thanks so much for answering our
questions ah Thank You Chelsea
sorry I couldn't be there in person but
I'm out in a road promoting my new book
you're only human
shameless Puglia I completely understand
now Gekko do people recognize you on the
street actually Chelsea I mean people
don't usually know his ministry because
I'm only six point nine inches tall I
spend most of my time just try not to
get stepped on but I do get better
tables at restaurants and I used to is
there a downside to all this Fame well
it seems the more famous you are the
more likely someone is to dig up your
old yearbook photos and look what we dug
up Oh
oh you're showing this on yeah so
seriously Chelsea awful we were friends
oh no I'm gonna remember this I just
couldn't resist well it's been great
talking with you and I wish you the best
of luck on your book tour ah Thank You
Chelsea now it's been great chatting
with ya
okay so that awkward stilted voice over
that was Chelsea Clinton a President
Bill Clinton's daughter doing a special
report there's a lot of air quotes I
don't especially was doing a children's
book what is going okay so that is
Barack Center this is a news program you
know it's one of these news magazine
things that was a bought advertisement
for Geico with the former president's
daughter talking to an imaginary lizard
I don't even know what question to ask
you guys go give me something
now unfortunately this is what the
media's become you know that's they
don't the real problems they don't even
see that as a problem yeah they're like
you what do you mean yeah and and notes
that's not a news report that's a that's
a giant ad I know that like you're in
the ad business that's how you get paid
I understand that there supposed to be a
firewall which you've totally forgotten
about where the ad is not supposed to
cross over into content yeah and you
know they like what planet is this guy
from we shall just to be clear that
they're actually selling that book so
this was not like some in a real book
yeah it's a real the lizard the
imaginary lizard made up an imaginary a
real book he's crazy the imaginary
lizard made up a real book and is
selling off to an imaginary reporter who
happens to be a real Wow yeah I mean is
this is this all we can expect these
days like the line seems to be gone but
should what what can we do what can we
do there's nothing we can do I mean it's
it it's all about the money these days
and uh it's all about that advertisement
and now you've seen they've stooped as
low as using the president's daughter
and doing their commercials now yeah so
I see this this gets talked about this
type of thing gets talked about all the
time and this is sort of like all that
you know that the Democrats is we're
brothers we were all screwed but really
genuinely what can people do to like
this is a small scale thing that I think
people could get upset about like we
can't have advertisements in our news
programs like if it's gonna start with
this it's not that we're not that far
from the end which is all bad so what
really can people do okay well so two
things number one I really you gotta
have truth in labeling right that that's
the thing that I'm most concerned about
like with foxes if they just came out
and said I know we're just kidding about
that fair balanced stuff obviously we're
conservatives right and we obviously
want to help the Republican Party I'd
like fine great have a toss that make
sense right there there's nothing wrong
that does that as long as you're honest
about it and if it Rock Center said oh
by the way we gotta pay the bills so we
a Chelsea do this goofy thing that's an
ad yeah I'm okay I get it that's an ad
right but it once they make it seem like
it's part of the news that's not kosher
if you ask me so how do we get beyond it
I mean my our whole network is a way of
getting around and this is not an act
yeah ironic I know but no but seriously
you know in all series is impart of the
reason I saw The Young Turks was uh the
one Achilles heel of the media is how we
can fix them in terms of they love to
copy like if something works worked okay
give me another one okay that boy band
is working give me another one just like
it right and whatever their ethnicity is
their ages I want an identical one and
then you got bugs and then you have ants
you remember the two movies again which
came out at the exact same exact same
time I hate for Christ's sake I mean how
specific can you beat two movies about
and
yeah okay Neville cartoons anyway so
we're hoping that if we do something
that's reality based and that's real you
know news and real commentary were
honest were progressives you know we
admit that etcetera a in that people go
wow how did they get all those views
maybe we should try being honest you
know and I've had that right I think
there's so much miscommunication and
just such bad information out there uh
that people are confused people and
that's why I think people the government
wants I want to be uneducated in this in
this country because they want to keep
them down keep them Dom so anything that
reports you on fox news whatever you're
gonna believe uh we need a little truth
meter at the corner of every single uh
network and it's a meters like lying to
whatever in whatever's being said
commercial everything that little thing
is that the truth or not everyone's
asleep here yeah well then you see who
tell the truth and that's exactly the
thing they fear the most that's whether
a candy crowley wing during the debates
when she fact check Mitt Romney you know
the Republicans flipped out and at the
end after the election they said our
biggest mistake was allowing Candy
Crowley to be a moderator cuz she had a
truth meter for like one time right like
one question right have the truth this
is a day when they flipped out they're
like that's Lance Bass is idea we can't
have that it's dangerous yeah all right
so final point on this I think the even
the bigger problem then than that as big
a problem is at is is what about this
way that we treat this aristocracy of
the Clintons and the bushes I mean this
girl should not have this job it's just
as simple as that
there are journalism students out there
you both worked hard in your respective
professions to get where you are so how
bad should how do we change the culture
of just because your parent is a
president a Jenna Bush has a job also in
in media I think does she work for NBC
also as I think she works for NBC so I
guess maybe there's just an NBC they
what and obviously stands for nepotism
but is that is that just a huge problem
to that it's just we we get these names
and then we want more but they need to
be responsible and you know and I know
Chelsea and that she's a brilliant
brilliant girl um and I wish you would
use those smarts that she has and do
something that she wants to report on I
know she's probably being told you have
to do this now maybe she's doing this
you know under the radar right now so
she gets the point where she can do the
story she wants to do but right now it's
not happening and I think you know she's
a smart lady she has a great point by
Lance if she broke a story about like
government corruption or something
how awesome would that be and how much
attention would again they would put her
immediately in the likes of her dad and
her mother like she would be like its
Chelsea Clinton look how smart is right
and it would help it would help the
country if she if she did it right but
ironically don't you think she actually
doesn't need something like that because
we keep the Clintons and the bushes and
there's a couple other families in such
a separate class from the rest of us
that she knows if she wants to be
senator from New York if Chelsea Glynn
was a New York in six years she will be
I mean it's just a simple no it drives
me crazy it's uh I like our royalty and
the Kennedys I mean we're like seven
generations deep and like you have a
Kennedy is your last name like well okay
welcome to a you know congressional seat
in the Northeast why why would we assign
just because it has Kennedy in the last
name that he's going to be smart or good
or in it center and then the bushes okay
okay welcome I hate that I think that's
I to me it's antithetical to everything
that America supposed to stand
absolutely I said this to the camera
last time we left England because they
had a king and we had representation we
we a taxation without representation and
we should not have families that are
running the show let's move on uh you
know what you know well let's not move
on right here you know I saw Michelle
Obama the other day on arrows and it
like I had this epiphany person go of
course she's next it like I hadn't
thought
until then for whatever reason and I was
like this is your whole prediction right
now well look it depend I don't know her
mind I don't know what she wants but if
she wants it a Senate seats a near
guarantee right I don't think she would
ever I mean she's
she sees what her husband's gone through
I don't think anyone would want that for
their lives except that you know when
she did the Oscars it was really good PR
for her and that's not a mistake and it
made me think maybe they're grooming her
you know hopefully they're grooming her
for education reform health and all that
type of stuff so hopefully I mean cuz
she does great you know works with that
right so cuz they don't see her taking a
Senate seat but I hope that she does
more of that even after he leaves the
White House I hope she's the face of
especially this health crisis that we
have in America well now she's trying to
get kids to not be obese and the
Republicans are yelling at her because
we have every we're free we should be
open my big gulp oh yeah yeah that's
actually why I have the shape did I do
it was for freedom you've done it for
free every night here's a big go before
bed I want to remind you guys that the
official outfitter of the Reuben report
is bonobos go to bonobos com use code TR
r20 and get yourself this fancy shirt